a memorable last scene can make a good
movie great but which marvel movie
really broke the mold what exactly was
nick cage doing in the wicker man how
did one british comedy inspire a
thousand funerals keep watching to find
out warning spoilers ahead for all the
movies discussed
fight club david fincher's 1999
adaptation of the 1996 chuck palahniuk
novel is one of those movies where the
big twist ending forces you to reassess
everything you've just seen
the reveal that tyler durden is the
narrator's alternate personality might
raise a little confusion about specific
plot mechanics but it immediately brings
the story's themes into focus tyler is
the unhealthy projection of the
narrator's own rage self-loathing and
toxic masculinity an internal antagonist
who needs to be defeated the climactic
twist comes straight from the book but
the movie offers its own spin on the
ultimate resolution though the narrator
kills tyler project mayhem actually
succeeds and tyler's carefully planted
bombs are detonated in the darkly
hilarious finale the narrator tells
marla you met me at a very strange time
in my life
buildings explode around them as the
pixies where is my mind leads into the
credits this ending was actually
censored in china although ironically
the censored version is closer to
palink's novel
in many ways dr strange is one of the
more formulaic marvel origin stories
with steven strange's character arc
having a lot in common with that of tony
stark in the first iron man movie what a
relief it is then when the climax of the
movie breaks significantly from the
standard mcu formula whereas most marvel
movies build up to giant fight scenes
between the heroes and villains scott
derrickson's 2016 film finds a more
clever method for the sorcerer supreme
to save earth from the cosmic terror of
durmamu strange's strategy initially
appears to be an attempted diplomacy he
announces his intention to bargain with
dormammu at which point the dark
dimension ruler promptly kills him it
soon becomes clear however that
strange's true plan is to annoy dormammu
into submission as he has trapped both
himself and or mamu in a time loop in
which strange keeps coming back to be
killed again and again and again
i've come to bargain
eventually dormammu gets so sick of the
loop that he agrees to strange's terms
to leave earth alone no doubt more
superhero movies could benefit from the
inventive use of superpowers displayed
in this unique showdown
director adam mckay's don't look up was
one of the most divisive films of 2021
it was one of netflix's most watched
movies ever and accrued many award
nominations including one for best
picture at the oscars but reviews were
mixed even those who generally disliked
the apocalyptic satire however have
acknowledged that the film is at its
best when it finds genuine pathos in the
character's final night on earth with
the ultra rich escaping to outer space
and the comet about to deliver the
extinction of mankind dr randall mindy
decides to spend one last dinner
together with friends and family ewell
the christian anarchist skater played by
timothy chalamet leads the group in
prayer before dinner and everyone
expresses the things they're grateful
for even as the world is literally
ending around them critics have
disagreed about the movie as a whole but
there's no denying the power of its
final moments
many of pixar's movies save their most
emotional moments for the end the ending
of monsters university the 2013 prequel
to monsters inc stands out by elevating
what is otherwise a cute but
unexceptional parody of college movies
into something that genuinely lives up
to pixar's high standard of quality
there are many family movies about
following your dreams but monsters
university is one of the few to
acknowledge that dreams can fail and
change no matter how hard he tries mike
wazowski realizes he's never going to be
scary that's okay though because he
finds there are other things he's good
at such as working as a scare assistant
mike
you're not scary
not even little but you are fearless
both mike and sully end up expelled for
all the trouble they cause but they find
they don't need to follow the set path
of academia to succeed instead they
apply for jobs in the mail room at
monsters inc and the credits sequence
shows them gradually working their way
up the corporate ladder it's an unusual
but positive message of flexibility and
compromise
writer director celine skiama is
talented at many things but her greatest
talent might be found in the endings to
her movies portrait of a lady on fire
her 2019 historical lesbian romance is a
slow burn with a powerful conclusion
romantic tensions gradually build up
between the painter marianne and her
aristocratic subject eloise but their
affair is brief and marianne only sees
eloise twice after it's over the first
time is at an art exhibit the second
time is at the orchestra and it's the
ending which turns the film into one of
the all-time great tearjerkers portrait
of a lady on fire uses music extremely
sparingly only in scenes where the
characters are actually performing or
singing as a result when music is heard
in the film its effect is extremely
powerful the orchestra in the final
scene is playing the presto from summer
in vivaldi's four seasons the same piece
of music marianne once played for eloise
eloise doesn't know marianne is
observing her in the audience for this
concert but when she hears this music
she appears overwhelmed with the
memories of her love it's an incredible
piece of filmmaking on skiama's part
supported by a superb performance by
adele hendell
at the start of 1973's f for fake
filmmaker orson welles assures the
audience
during the next hour everything you'll
hear from us is really true and based on
solid facts
he spends the next hour talking about
various real-life hoaxes from art
forgeries to the fictional news
broadcasts in his own 1938 war of the
worlds radio drama but f for fake runs
longer than an hour and in its final 28
minutes it becomes one of the very fakes
the first hour was documenting wells is
honest about his bakery of course all
his assurances of truth at the beginning
were clearly stated to last just one
hour and at the end of the film he
openly admits to lying his head off
during the 17 minute story about his
partner and co-writer oya kodar modeling
for and swindling picasso in an era of
fake news well's trolling deconstruction
of the documentary format is more
relevant than ever
christopher nolan's 2006 film the
prestige concludes with several
mind-blowing twists each of the
magicians is hiding secrets for hugh
jackman's robert angier the secret is
that he's able to pull off the
transported man magic trick through
actual magic of sorts cloning himself
with a machine built by nikola tesla
christian bale's alfred borden performs
the trick using a very different secret
he's not actually one person but twin
brothers sharing a single identity one
borden is hanged after being framed for
killing anger who's secretly still alive
under the identity of lord caldlow the
other borden gets his revenge and kills
the last remaining anger whose theater
burns down with all his dead clones
inside great twist endings are hard to
pull off but the prestige is a movie
designed around its many revelations
meticulously following the steps that
make a great magic trick work
set in a motel outside of disney world
the florida project centers around
mooney a six-year-old girl having fun
with her friends while her loving but
neglectful single mother haley struggles
to make ends meet it's a movie that's
repetitive by design to best get across
the reality of life in poverty but the
ending shakes up this repetition in a
manner both heartbreaking and absolutely
stunning
eventually things get bad enough that
child services come to take mooney away
from haley in this moment of deep pain
mooney and her friend janzi escape and
run away to the magic kingdom people
have debated whether the disney world
scene is meant to be real or the
children's fantasy but however you
interpret it the conclusion makes the
film as a whole even more memorable and
affecting
fans might argue over which monty python
movie is the funniest but monty python's
life of brian is definitely the one with
the strongest story one which leads to
the strongest ending by far this
irreverent often censored 1979 comedy
follows brian a very naughty boy living
in proximity to jesus who is
accidentally mistaken for the messiah at
the end of the film brian has been
sentenced to death by crucifixion and
all attempts to save him go horribly
awry reg what are you going to do come
on
and thanks
unable to do anything to escape his slow
and painful death the other crucified
men cheer brian up by singing always
look on the bright side of life
optimistic nihilistic absurdist
extremely british there are lots of ways
you can describe the comedic
juxtaposition of eric idol's silly
upbeat song with the direness of its
context whatever you want to call it
though it clearly struck a chord in 2014
always look on the bright side of life
was revealed to have been the most
frequently requested funeral song in the
united kingdom
neil labute's 2006 remake of the wicker
man is not considered a good horror
movie by most people's standards in the
final moments of its unrated cut however
it certainly becomes memorable though
there are several amusing displays of
overacting from nicolas cage throughout
the film none compares to the scene
where the villagers torture him with
these resulting in the now legendary
line love the beast
i love my eyes
in a 2022 interview with indy wire cage
claimed the comedy of this scene was
intentional and that he and labute
actually wanted the film to go further
with the ridiculousness he said it
probably would have been more clear how
funny it was if producer abby lerner let
me have the handlebar mustache that i
wanted to wear and be burned in the bear
suit that would have been so horrifying
but they didn't go for that because all
the comedy would have emerged from this
horror he pointed to the horrifying yet
also darkly comedic conclusion of
midsummer as a more successful example
of what the wickerman remake was aiming
for michael curtis's 1942 drama
casablanca is a movie that's so beloved
as a classic that basically every line
has become a cliche and it's still a
delight to watch 80 years later from
beginning to end casablanca is a
brilliantly entertaining movie with
clever writing and captivating romantic
chemistry between humphrey bogart's rick
blaine and ingrid bergman's ilsa lund
it's the story's conclusion however that
truly seals this as one of the greatest
american films ever made rick a
character who was once a celebrated
freedom fighter but has since become
cynical and disillusioned regains his
heroism at a time when the world truly
needs it he sacrifices his change to
stay with ilsa in order to help her and
her husband escape from the nazis he's
looking at you kid
indeed casablanca is a work of wartime
propaganda made with such moral heft and
great storytelling that it elevates
itself to become a powerful work of art
george romero's knight of the living
dead shocked moviegoers in 1968 with its
groundbreaking gore and fresh take on
the zombie mythos for all the terror of
its flesh-eating undead though the
ending of the film shows how ordinary
humans can be the scariest monsters of
all ben the movie's black hero has done
his best to survive throughout the film
but in the end he's killed by some white
men with guns who seemingly mistake him
for a zombie romero didn't intentionally
write knight of the living dead with
race in mind but regardless of what the
filmmaker initially intended the ending
was widely viewed as a subversive
commentary on racism its implications
are unfortunately no less scary today
than they were when the movie was first
released you can credit night of the
living dead and particularly its ending
for helping lead the way for such
racially conscious horror films as
candyman and get out check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]